so let me just bring you some breaking  news um sky sports news has confirmed  that uefa is going to move this year's  champions league final from saint  petersburg  in the wake of what's happened today and  russia's invasion of ukraine it was a  great deal of speculation about whether  or not that would happen there were a  lot of calls  for uefa to make that move and make sure  that the champions league final would  not happen on russian soil in saint  petersburg and sky news has confirmed  that uefa will indeed move that final  from petersburg and we understand that  an announcement on that is expected  shortly so when that happens we will of  course bring it to you